of order 66 you were a young lady
we called it you you saw him we called
it he called this and he killed the
others that's enough he killed the other
young man somehow enough
uh-oh
oh boy
oh no
oh no
[Music]
oh my god are we gonna
oh
oh my god we're actually seeing this
revenge of the sith cut away and showed
on the holo screens this is
hard to look at
oh
what is with these heroic droids and the
more recent star wars
it's just yeah okay
kqso
oh
this is so sad
the the violin music is breaking my
heart right now
oh
[Music]
with
damn
oh damn
fire in the hole
oh
damn
oh
damn oh man
not again
oh my god oh my god
[Music]
wow
whoa
how did she
how did that kid survive that i don't
know
oh oh my god he hit her in the same spot
did not see it youngling
you see it that whole time
kenobi always underestimates him he's
like yeah he won't be able to tell it to
you
yeah yeah no no he saw he knew
um
still here revenge does wonders i have
two stomachs
what's your excuse for surviving um i
like how fancy the grand inquisitor is
i know yeah he wears white gloves
revenge does wonders for the will to
live
i just went to a novelist
seminar in new haven
we're spending the week in the hamptons
i own a yacht
my wife changes people for sport
and i have an open arrangement
pete campbell and i from mad men our
soul name is he is he is he's the he's
the star wars aunt
welcome back to new rock stars the third
sister riva is confirmed to be our poor
order 66 youngling back in the gutter
now somehow still alive as flashbacks to
prequel era hayden christensen both
delight and terrify us but what's next
for riva on
this is wikileaks our weekly reaction to
obi-wan kenobi on disney plus i'm eric
voss my easter egg breakdown is coming
tomorrow but right here i'm with tommy
bechtold
thoughts after this episode wow what an
episode uh yeah just packed
packed with star warsy goodness and uh
some predictions of ours you know kind
of coming true coming to fruition
feels good yeah feels good we now
understand why rupert frind was on uh
jimmy kimmel live on friday night uh
jimmy doing his best to pull those
spoilers out from uh rupert and rupert
staying steadfast but with a little
twinkle in his eye that i think let us
know
i feel personal vindication that he came
back in episode five because all my
haters were saying nope it'll be a
episode six reveal and i said no no no
you get the appetizer in five you get
the grand inquisitor returning in five
and then you get him in full force
spinning that saber around like a
helicopter blade
in six
see i think oh i oh god we gotta get the
spin we got to get the helicopter yeah
float right to me the main course is
qui-gon like that yeah next episode yes
i got it i need me some nissan give me
some quick guns
but the
the uh i mean can we talk about the
the de-aging on uh i mean or the lack
thereof yeah and uh hayden christensen
and ewan mcgregor to this pre-attack of
the clones era yeah a little bit but he
still looks like he still looks
significantly older i didn't mind guys i
just like seeing these faces yeah i
thought it was smart to do it this way
because it didn't throw me i was like
all right they look like they like they
did like clearly they did some smoothing
but not like you said like it wasn't
like a full
fake person you know what i mean like i
mean i'd be surprised if they come out
and they're like yeah we completely
rendered this like face from nothing
like i feel like it was more just like
an us weekly touch-up on a magazine
article you know what i mean like it was
like i thought
and i mean that was finally i think
the hayden christensen performed like
what we were looking waiting for for
this series was like i hope they go back
to something like that next week too i
don't know that might have been a
one-time dish but it was just great to
see them interacting like that and
seeing
the stubborn anakin that still loved
obi-wan you know even in the end after
he's been embarrassed by him in a
teachable moment he's still kind of like
half smiling like all right you got me
you know like there was still so much
good in him right absolutely let's let's
break down what happened this episode so
yeah we open with this flashback and
this is sometime before attack the
clones because yeah anakin's still a
short-haired padawan he still has all of
his limbs he's still using his
lightsaber from before attack of the
clones in the first part of that movie
obi-wan is now this long slick-haired
master doing his best to carry out
qui-gon's wishes uh
spending some time at night uh having
some dreams about duchess sateen some a
woman he'll one day meet in the years
ahead on clone wars um they spar in this
training session blue on blue
i just think tommy these flashbacks are
beautifully interwoven throughout the
episode they're framed mostly as vader's
memories of this lesson that he never
truly learned it's kind of like that one
memory of your of your teacher or mentor
who told you something that you didn't
truly appreciate and just kind of left
you a little pissed off and confused
and and then different experiences
throughout your life force you to think
back on that moment realize oh i'm on
the other side of the clouds now right i
kind of get it uh i don't know if vader
gets it yet from this episode because uh
you know he's still kind of an [ __ ]
yeah but i i mean that's kind of the
argument is if uh you know obi-wan is
still the teacher you know uh vader's
still the learner uh but by the end of
the series i don't i think
vader will have learned his final lesson
from him um
but he's gonna learn it in the way that
serves him now in his current mission
which is not a good one uh but i also
just love how this memory by the end of
the episode is something that is shared
with obi-wan obi-wan is just thinking
back is dwelling on the same moment
again the force is drawing these two
together by forcing them to think back
on this this one throw away moment they
probably did hundreds of these training
sessions together right terrace
ultimately yeah i think it's great that
this was this is exactly what i wanted
between you and mcgregor and hayden
christensen on this series it's like a
chance to revisit
a kind of vibe between them that existed
on clone wars but we didn't necessarily
see enough well i don't know maybe you
saw enough of it in attack of the clones
and revenge of the set there were some
wholesome moments between them uh but i
just liked revisiting that and having
this uh this touchstone that can inform
their current conflict uh in such a
beautiful way the fact that we revisited
it like three or four times throughout
the episode was just really cool yeah
for sure i i don't have like as sharp an
eye for like de-aging and like whether
vfx looks like perfect and pristine when
i first watch it because this might just
be because i grew up doing like shitty
theater in my high school where people
were wearing like cardboard costumes
right so like that willing suspension of
disbelief is like dialed up to eleven
and i think i'm in the same way as you
yeah i know it's not real it just all
looks animated and and cgi to me anyway
so i'm connecting to the characters at
this moment i don't care if it looks
photorealistic always
yeah absolutely yeah i i feel like i'm
the same as you i i don't have a very
good yeah say like i don't have a very
good i don't have a keen eye for it like
i'm like oh okay this is like so clearly
not him or so clearly like a changed
face i'm like yeah all right whatever
that's him
like i think when i uh like people are
gonna grill me for this but when i saw
like uh um tarkin and rogue one i was
like
ah was the lay at the end of rogue one i
was like oh yeah when i watch ryze at
skywalker even and they recreated carrie
fisher i'm like ooh they did it pretty
good yeah like i'm just so easily won
over absolutely
um but um yeah yeah what if we just find
out this whole uh series like hayden
christensen's like yeah i was never on
saturday i never showed you crazy i
wasn't there once they're just really
good at it
they used free speecher uh they did a
great job yeah oh my god um vader
promotes riva to grand inquisitor making
her kneel which is interesting because
she hesitates but obviously we learned
that that's triggering her memory of him
looming over her in this posture uh so
obi-wan leia broken and sully returned
to jabim no one says a goddamn word
about wade
you know how we need we need an hour of
silence for wade justice for winning get
it here disappointing justice for wade
uh
wayne's was barb in the upside down
somewhere wade is
that's right that's right gonna spin off
um obi-wan reunites with hajja sees more
orbesh jedi names and phrases i'm gonna
translate all those in the breakdown
don't worry also enough lightsabers to
make general grievous they're always
yeah forever i'll id as many of those as
i can to the breakdown too um but evil
lola activates cutting some circuits
sealing their uh their hanger doors riva
forces riva's forces lay siege to the
base uh they try to get the doors open
um you know so they can escape while
they seal all the other doors uh leia
crawls into a vent to work the wires
cool i don't know why it had to be her
because so one of those other other
little kids done it who maybe have they
were like
married
poor i feel like poor o'shea jackson has
gotten the short end of the uh
dialogue and plot stick in this show
cause like i i'm very much enjoying this
show but like last week they had his
character be like
under no circumstances can we help you
it would be crazy for us to help you and
then like obi-wan says one thing and he
goes you need anything from me and i
will absolutely do it no matter what it
was like it was such a 180 in the span
of 30 seconds
for like i feel like today he was like i
can't crawl through a vent i'm too big
then leia's like i got these big strong
arms and i like to eat i'm a man yeah i
can't go in the vent
he's good he's definitely getting the
role of the like yeah the like guy that
if this was like an army movie he would
get cut down by like a space laser
immediately like if he was yeah he's the
brat yeah but yeah good for him good for
him for being in star wars anyway uh
obi-wan stalls by talking to riva
through the door and it is confirmed
that riva was the young lean from the
order 66 prologue scene uh at the
beginning of the series and we learned
that anakin stabbed her and that's how
she knows anakin is vader i guess you
just don't forget a guy who stabs you
like you see you see andy can't go that
dark you just kind of can tell by the
way he walks in the way he swings his
lightsaber like oh that's probably the
same guy yeah
um
she says she hid among the bodies and
played dead
which
i'm amazed that they kept that in the
episode for sure yeah because they put
the disclaimer at the top i'm not saying
that i think it's good that they kept it
in right for sure like we shouldn't we
should be triggered by these things well
yeah i mean it's like i yeah i mean
the fact that that has parallels to to
to real-life things is is more of an
indictment on real life not the show you
know like their fantasy good point you
know their fantasy exercise and survival
is yeah i don't i it's like i don't
think they should be apologizing for
you know something they wrote
two years ago that unfortunately has
recent parallels and i i'm glad they
left it in like you said like it's like
yeah i don't yeah i don't there's a
longer issue to talk about that but
yeah absolutely um
the one thing they leave out from her
story there is how exactly she survived
after that yeah how she got out of the
temple how she ended up uh with the
inquisitors
we're going to talk more about that in a
bit um but riva suddenly gets the idea
to cut through the door with their
lightsaber pulling a good qui-gon uh to
black to melt down the blast door but
here it looks like she wedges it doesn't
look like she melts it down she just
does it in the door it's like okay i'm
open now um so
this leads to this shootout where uh ned
b gets a great moment where he kind of
vader someone up to the ceiling but you
know he and tala do not make it it's
tragic uh tala detonates a thermal
detonator obi-wan surrenders tries to
force riva to join him against vader um
it seems like he moves the needle a
little bit but she hasn't taken back
inside to wait for vader for some reason
i'm not really sure why
they couldn't just leave them there
to me it was that was almost
her indicating that she was game for the
plan
like okay
yes that was my thought like she knew he
would be able to dispatch of a couple of
stormtroopers pretty easily
and was like yeah all right take him
inside so that way he doesn't have to do
this with like 50 of you you just do
this with like three of you right yeah
yeah and i'm glad that like uh they
didn't try to stretch out this uh
duplicitousness between arriva and vader
to two episodes because i feel like yeah
arriva's decisions eventually were gonna
out themselves uh in this episode uh so
i'm glad we got this duel between them
uh but yeah so obi-wan does slip away uh
there's an amazing moment where vader
hunts him down and force pulls the
transport shot back down not just
holding it back slams it back down rips
off the pieces of it that to me was like
holy [ __ ] like one of like my top five
look how powerful this guy is it's like
crazy yeah
yeah i love it it was vicious and you
know no one's on this ship right it was
this insane fake out where the other
ship was right there vader didn't sense
those engines firing up i guess
chewbacca was on a different transport
it was kind of that right i mean hey
someone had to pilot this other
transport that guy's dead
that guy's gone he's like you know what
okay fine maybe they made one of the
astromechs just do it on their own but
that astromech is gone yeah either way
vader's gonna beat that thing to hell oh
yeah
so then we get this great duel between
riva and vader and i love how at first
vader only uses the force like until he
snaps her double-bladed saber and duels
her with the other half of it and he
defeats her and stabs her inside
triggering her moment where anakin
stabbed her during order 66
uh and yeah the grand inquisitor returns
alive and well reclaims his old grand
inquisitor badge so rebels fans don't
worry we're
on it reeva crawls over to obi-wan's
hollow communicator that hajj has
dropped finding the scrambled message
from bail organa mentioning tatooine and
owen and the boy and obi-wan senses this
discovery from his shuttle and he his
mind trips back to tatooine to the lars
homestead and luke sleeping soundly in
his bed
so
the question now is how exactly does
riva survive both this time and when she
was a kid uh and what is her next move
as we look ahead to the finale how does
this all end before we talk about that
we want you to head on over to
newrockstarsmerch.com to grab our
obi-wan kenobi themed latest obsession
shirt empire's most wanted i bring it
here i love it i need it i got it come
on
give me that give me give give me that
epic hero give me that give me that
latest obsession new rock stars tommy
needs it this limited edition shirt
won't be available much longer so make
sure you get a chance to grab it before
it's gone and when you purchase his
latest obsession shirt you'll unlock the
ability to get a shout out featured
right here in wikileaks uh let's see we
got john travis says
i'm a jedi on an eop
ride i'm wanted
by the dark side
john
your uh your poetry
was the highlight of our morning here
yeah i want to thank you uh neon victor
asks what's your favorite lightsaber
um i mean to me i think maul's
lightsaber from yeah i mean that when i
was a kid
that was definitely my favorite
lightsaber but you know as you get older
you
grow more mature and nostalgic i think
i'm a sucker for a classic kenobi
lightsaber you know i yeah i love that
lightsaber but yeah when i was uh
however old i was 12 or 13 when
uh
the first prequel came out
or maybe a little older i was darth maul
all the way and then mitchell says help
me eric voss i'm on the east coast i
want to see your improv well uh
mitchell i'm doing you a favor my improv
is not always that great but it's nice
i've done a lot of improv with eric and
it'll be well worth it we're gonna get
to the east coast for you guys don't
worry some way somehow yeah new
rockstars wants to go on tour i'll just
say i don't know where on the east coast
you are but like we do want to like take
the show on the road absolutely so we'll
give you all the updates i don't know if
you'll see me do improv shows but maybe
i'll i'll know some of the look i do
know like improvisers and cities
you might see me in there because i'll
be
right
eric and i could pop up in some dingy
basement
and do a quick improv session where you
never know maybe we get off-screen
producer zach he's a great improviser
there's so many good improvisers that do
rock stars that
sometimes brandon barrick one of the
funniest improvisers you'll ever see
okay i wasn't talking about him
brandon is spectacular yes
yeah um all right let's dive into this
episode what's our what's our first
question eric how and why is riva still
alive yeah so yeah this episode confirms
what we've been speculating from the
opening shot of this series that the
first young ling we saw in that terrace
of the jedi temple was in fact riva
apparently that's how she knew anakin
was vader she saw anakin savagery as he
killed the younglings in the temple she
recognized his movements and his
presence when he later appeared suited
up as vader and made the connection that
way reeva apparently never forgave vader
for stabbing her through her stomach as
a kid and who could blame her obi-wan
manages to flip her this episode but
when she draws her lightsaber on vader
vader subdues her for seeing her her
treachery and her betrayal uh and he
does this without even drawing his own
lightsaber which feels like uh a
disrespect right yeah he does not
respect her enough to even draw his own
lightsaber it's like yeah it's also
youngling it's kind of like those um
those like swashbuckling movies of like
the 60s and 50s where like the master
swordfighter would put his hands behind
his back and just dodged yeah exactly
you got it
yes
yeah yes exactly i can do it i can do it
immediately get stabbed in my neck we
get this great cross-cutting moment
where riva relives this same man
stabbing her the same exact way as he
did before and i think that might
actually be how she survives his stab so
let's dig into it because riva said she
survived order 66 by hiding among the
bodies playing dead but there must have
been more to that story of young riva's
survival from the temple that night like
someone either found her or she was able
to crawl out of there alone um the grand
inquisitor said they found her quote in
the gutter but the emperor according to
the timeline from chuck's souls uh 2017
comics the emperor did not create the
inquisitor program until sometime after
order 66 it's not like he had it ready
to go that night and then like she
crawled into a gutter the grand
inquisitors like that one but by the
time
vader found out that the inquisitors
were operational uh when he was in his
suit he like this was after he had
chased down a kyber crystal to bleed
into uh and after he started making
mustafar or like going on these side
missions from the emperor and then he
comes back to talk to the emperor and
then he runs into the grand inquisitive
and he's like oh inquisitors exist so
it's implied that like there was a
period of at least a few months maybe a
couple years
uh that riva would have been on her own
and then ended up in the gutter uh and
during that time
she was a kid maybe she could have
survived on her own obviously there's
there's kids all over this galaxy who
are able to survive on their own but
like part of that survival process is
she could have patched up her wound with
some nice wheat magic from thundercat
giving her some phoenix chan pistons in
the stomach likes but either way this is
patched in a specific way that allowed
her to survive
um actually you know we should take a
moment to reach here and speculate that
whoever smuggled grogu out that night
might have also helped out a wounded
young riva yeah maybe she just got
separated at some point landed in the
gutter
i would love to have some sort of
exploration on that whether it's a movie
or like another limited series like the
the the immediate aftermath of order 66
that would be yeah
i'm sure they have plans and in the
meantime if like every single star wars
series can just slash back to that night
and show it from a different point of
view i'm okay with that too absolutely
that seems to be the game plan right now
so the grand inquisitor returns he
survived his own lightsaber stat but in
his case powents have two stomachs
actually mentioned jimmy kimmel rupert
friend referenced that in an interview
he's like well one of my stomachs yeah
that's half cup is his survival yeah uh
and he makes this glib comment about uh
riva
having revenge feeding the will's will
to survive he's not wrong if you think
about it revenge definitely helped maul
survived far worse wounds than this for
years
i think the reason rita survives vader's
stab now is that vader deliberately
aimed for the same exact spot that he
stabbed it before a wound that would be
patched with machinery or pistons or
whatever it is as opposed to like vital
organs so if it can be uh if it was
repaired through artificial means before
it can be repaired now um but it still
hurts i think you know you tore open
painful scar tissue uh it's just one
blow that won't necessarily kill her i
guess the question is why did vader
leave her alive why didn't he and the
grand inquisitor just execute her in
this moment because vader's done that
plenty of other times with a with mouthy
inquisitors before
and i think uh the fact that vader never
used his own lightsaber against her and
called her youngling indicates that he
just doesn't respect her enough to kill
her
i think he may also foresee something
that the grand inquisitor doesn't yet
that reva's rage might actually still be
useful against obi-wan i wonder if vader
leaving her alive has something to do
with the fact that he was left alive
you know and like in a in a very
weakened destroyed state and if there's
something about him knowing that the
true torture is having to live on past
this these failures and these
humiliations and like for him he's like
okay i could kill you but i've basically
disarmed you to the point where you
can't hurt me and now i've once again
for the second time
driven a lightsaber through you so go
ahead and like yeah like like live on
with this shame and this mental torture
just as i kind of fight that battle in
my brain every day and like sure there
are certain people that he'll just kill
instantly because that's the ultimate he
doesn't have respect for life obviously
but like for people like riva that he
feels extremely disrespected by he
realizes the true punishment is
surviving beyond this that's really
great analysis tommy i think you're
exactly right i think uh he says look
unleashing a rage monster on the world
isn't something that's uh like he's so
confident in his own abilities to repel
anything that she'd bring at him yeah uh
but knows that obi-wan is still
scrambling and weakened right so says
like i think that is uh that is
something that vader does when he trains
the inquisitors is he like brutalizes
them he cuts off their limbs and stuff i
think he knows that like rage is a
powerful weapon when you're mentoring
people because it worked for him so well
sure it keeps them motivated in a
horrible cruel statistic yeah let's be
clear like jk simmons and whiplash
absolutely absolutely
what a teacher fear is
so what's next right is she going to be
headed to tatooine and is obi-wan going
to fight her and vader in finale if this
happens on tatooine are they going to
reconcile that with vader having no idea
luke is on tatooine in a new hope like i
assume we're going to get a rematch
between obi-wan and vader right yeah
or is that i i feel like we have now
unfortunately for rifa's character she
has now entered the she knows too much
like level of a character knowing things
and
unless she fully turns into an ally of
obi-wan and like sacrifice either a
diverts vader away from like knows the
secret and uses it to divert vader away
or sacrifices herself
like i just don't see it ending well for
her now if she knows both
kind of if she's now basically pieced
together all of the secrets of the
original star wars trilogy
years before it happens it doesn't to me
seem like there's a
easy way out for her you know just to
survive beyond this yeah agreed like
she's the one character on this series
other than some other members of the
path whose fate we don't really know
yeah um
we we know obi-wan is gonna be fine we
know leia's gonna be fine vader's gonna
be fine grand inquisitor's gonna be fine
uh but riva is the one like
you know she could die but i also feel
like if she was gonna die on this series
wouldn't she have died in this episode
wouldn't they have just made this her
death i think the idea is that she's
gonna be left alive there's even some
talk of uh of riva getting a spin-off
series
if so i would want to know where that is
like i you know is season two going to
be about her trying to hunt luke i feel
like there's only so much story you
could do there because luke really never
left tattooing right so he had no idea
thing of luke walking around the town is
like she tries to swipe at him and like
can't get him
yeah
damn it how is he so good oh beyond just
like blocking her attack
they're both invisible exactly looks
like why do things explode around me all
the time
the uh i uh i hope that next episode we
get a rematch between obi-wan and vader
i feel like yeah
like i hope
as much as i love the flashback duel
between them
they the two need to lock sabers at
least once more yeah it's just that that
can't happen on tattooing and right now
it seems like obi-wan's headed b-line to
tatooine right so
we're kind of back where we were at the
start of the series when it comes to
speculation of how these two are going
to intersect like assuming that leia's
now safe headed back to i
here's my thinking is that like
you know i guess the question is sorry
does riva know that that was bail organa
it seemed like they deliberately
scrambled at being jimmy smits she just
couldn't she could hear what he was
saying she only got pieces but she
doesn't yeah yeah she doesn't know that
bailor ghana was in kahoot but she must
imagine no she knows that bailor gone in
yeah because
that's why she calls her during the
interrogation like my father is a
senator my father is bail organa or
whatever so like yeah she has to so yeah
does is this something where riva tries
to intercept uh leia going back to
alderaan and then they fight again there
i'm just wondering where this goes like
what exactly is going what what story is
left to tell it just seems like now it's
going back home to protect luke but
protect luke just from riva
is vader now off the chessboard that
can't be and and i i mean like
what would riva's motivations to getting
luke be would it be to hurt anakin or to
like
would it be revenge you know i think
she's trying to get back in his good
graces i think uh i don't think she
knows that leia and anakin
or leia and luke are anakin's kids right
i think that's so a secret uh but i
think she's trying again to draw out
obi-wan
uh in the same way that like oh
she i think she now knows that like leia
has a secret brother
that obi-wan is also protecting on
tatooine i think that's what she knows
got it um so yeah i think that's a whole
she's going to use it to try to get back
in either vader's good graces or just to
increase road stature or get revenge on
on obi-wan yeah uh because i think right
now she knows that she can't get back in
vader like she had her best shot yeah
she's never gonna get another shot of it
no not like that no all right we're
gonna talk about some more predictions
for the finale uh but first we want to
thank some friends who helped us make
this episode me undies when it comes to
the best movie series to binge one
particular franchise comes to mind a
long time ago in a galaxy far far away
star wars was born something that was
born not so long ago meundies new latest
star wars collab me undies is back with
more prints featuring your favorite
characters get ready for your next movie
marathon with the softest and comfiest
star wars collection watching the star
wars trilogy for the 500th time is true
comfort for me but nothing is more
comfortable than my me undies who
wouldn't feel more confident with chewie
on their underwear get this walking
carpet out of my way and into my pants
me undies loves partnering with your
favorite shows and movies and this isn't
the first time they've created a
collection with star wars the force is
strong with this one which is why
they're back with two new limited
edition prints lightspeed and rebel
squadron match your favorite person in
the galaxy or go solo
in sustainably soft undies socks
loungewear dog hoodies and more sizes
from extra small to 4xl meondis is a
great offer for our viewers for any
first-time purchasers you'll get 15 off
and me undies shift right to your door
to get 15 off your first order and a 100
happiness guarantee go to
meundies.comwookie
that's meundies.com wookie to ease and
wookie all right tommy let's look ahead
to finale and make some uh predictions
for what we think we will see next week
first off force ghost qui-gon jinn do
you think he's gonna show up gotta think
he'll help what we and do you think
vader will see qui-gon's ghost at any
point or would that require vader to be
on tatooine and that's not going to
happen i think obi-wan will see qui-gon
i don't think vader will i i think that
that like vader's seeing qui-gon
i feel like vader is completely
unredeemed until the original trilogy
you know what i mean like i don't see
vader you know what i mean having any
like i could see him having moments of
conflict but he's so brutal so ruthless
so bloodthirsty so arrogant right now
that i don't think like the shock of
seeing qui-gon is something that his
character's gonna go through i i gotta
you know i've obviously been wrong
before but i have a feeling this is
gonna be a
one on
one on gone experience one on qui-gon
with uh obi-wan and qui-gon do you think
um uh
we are done with both darth vader and
the grand inquisitor because you could
totally walk out of this episode and say
okay both of those characters are set up
for the next time we see them uh uh
darth vader in rogue one uh
uh grain inquisitor and rebels
yeah like
we could step away from them i just hope
we don't i hope you don't i wanna i just
yeah me too it just seems like their
issues are now resolved narratively
speaking uh i mean i would say that
vader still has a bit more of a lesson
to learn with uh
with obi-wan kenobi but you could also
argue that on the death star in a new
hope that's kind of the
thing i still think kenobi is gonna best
him and knock his mask off i still think
we're getting a hayden christensen in
the vader
with the mouthpiece
uh apparatus in the suit i think we're
getting that next week i just want to
know where that happens from from what i
i understand looking at trailer footage
all the trailer footage has now been
shown there was some footage of uh
of ned b
in
as it was being laid siege to but now i
don't think there is anything else
so all the stuff in the final episode we
have no idea i wish the final episode
had been like a secret movie and like
they were like at the end of last night
at the end of their today's drop they're
like and now next friday in theaters
kenobi the movie it's three hours long
and we've set up where it's where it
begins i would that what a great
freaking oh i would lose it trojan horse
that had been that would have been
disney steal that idea from me steal
that idea for me first yeah
well they are putting the whole series
in theaters which i think is interesting
yeah so and it does feel like the fact
that each episode is called parts like
part one part two three does feel like
this truly was intended to be a movie
yeah and that is that's why some
episodes feel like kind of a weird lull
in between story beats a little bit but
i think the uh
yeah
i gotta i'm with you tommy we gotta see
rematch and then yeah let's play some
bets the helicopter lightsaber move from
the grand inquisitor reba can't do it
hers is now severed in half grand
inquisitor fourth sister or fifth
brother do we think any of them will do
the helicopter float or will this series
view that it's too goofy no grand
inquisitor is doing it next week we're
getting it all next weekend i'm going
positive i'm bullish better i'm bullish
on kenobi i'm bearish on cryptocurrency
i'm bullish on kenobi
do we think reba is going to survive
this season no
i think next episode she's gone her i
think she sacrifices herself oh wow so
you think she'll be redeemed by the end
of it i do i think she's gonna be a
tragic character i agree i think uh i
think she's going to spare luke at the
end do you think obi-wan is going to
tell her who luke is
only if he knows for sure she's dying
only if she's mortally wounded i think
he might i mean he might you know the
new hope is supposed to you know is luke
right and a new hope is luke so that she
might be the first person to learn of
this new hope you know like outside of
the people on the inside uh good point i
think that might be the one thing that
allows riva to forgive obi-wan because
her whole thing was like where were you
when this when your padawan was killing
all my friends and tried to kill me like
where were you right now he can say like
look i've had to dedicate my life in
exile just like
sitting in the desert hoping that
nothing comes to this kid to try to hurt
him like that mission that exile could
be enough to make her realize oh okay no
this guy is uh he's definitely still on
the mission and he's trying to redeem
himself too so do we think we'll get a
second season of this series and if so
what would be the story of that second
season i i know that they are game
for it
i know that like obviously like the
actors have all said that they would
they're
specifically even mcgregor says he's
interested in doing more as kenobi
my question is at what point
does it become to have we are we telling
too much story and losing
the
isolation of the hermit ben kenobi
you know from a new hope i mean i think
there's still more story to tell and you
could step you could tell a you do
another six part story that's basically
taking place in the span of a month of
another time obi-wan was called off
planet but in a sense then he's
basically becoming like this
uh intergalactic a team right like it's
like all right
we've got a problem only kenobi can
solve this and like maybe you know it
does it doesn't seem as though
alec guinness in a new hope has become
like a more hopeful character so it's
not like these missions are all leading
kenobi to being you know like he just he
feels more dutiful at that point like i
watch over luke that's what i do i make
sure luke's okay that's my job and like
this like we still have kind of like
kenobi with a little bit of like urgency
to him
so i i guess i would i would love to see
a second season just because i love the
way you ewan mcgregor plays his
character
but i don't know if he could come into
con conflict with vader again you know
especially if they have one more duel
it's kind of like i don't know i mean
perhaps as a
you know
perhaps we could see
obi-wan as kenobi and other star wars
things i guess would be my best answer
right yeah i think um there's only so
many narrative levers he can pull for
this series to be interesting and to
exist at all i think the big draw is the
promise of the rematch between these two
characters of obi-wan yeah like right
now uh if you're trying to create a
series it's really hard to write a
series where you know the fates of every
character except one right that's kind
of the issue with the all-prequel series
better call saul i think is doing a
masterful job of that and they've
introduced new characters on that show
um uh
two new protagonists um that i think you
have no idea what happens to them um so
it's fascinating to watch to be honest
um with this all we had was riva
everyone else pretty much you know so
you'd have to do that again just kind of
put someone else in obi-wan's world and
at that point it's not really about
obi-wan
like
you can't really
there's i don't know how much more story
there is to tell the one obi-wan story
that i would love it's like let's go
back let's go back to the clone wars
let's do a live action clone wars i'd be
down for that
uh yeah because otherwise it's just
obi-wan like great we can see obi-wan
and black chrysant and fight outside the
lars homestead cool that's fun it's just
more desert stories but i don't know if
everyone would be down for that series i
would watch it for sure i'd love it yeah
me too all right so i'm very excited for
the finale i hope we get a pretty epic
rematch between
obi-wan and vader next week uh i'm very
excited
and i like that the series coming full
circle it's going back home back to
tattooing i'm i'm worried about luke but
not that worried because i think he's
he's pretty okay he's gonna be all right
yeah
we'll leave it there for this episode of
wikileaks again the easter egg breakdown
is coming later or no it's coming
tomorrow don't forget to check out our
meeting great merch options over at
newrockstarsmerchtrot.com follow me at
ea boss follow tommy tommy beck talk
follow new rockstar subscribe to
wikileaks wherever you get your podcasts
thank you for watching and goodbye
you